i did i was supposed to give a talk on
secret sharing over networks but then i
was very inspired by
professor tilathar's talk uh but i was
not like i'm not tilata right so i
couldn't just remove it i just kept it
and few slides at the end so that if
someone just comes at me with
why did you remove it i can still show
them something
so
i thought so there was a lot of like
we we heard a lot of talks about
distributed storage in particular
regarding uh locality local repair of
codes and
so tamu gave a wonderful talk this
morning and then professor vijay kumar
gave a talk
during the lightning talk
sergey yakunin
uh
put forward quite few questions but uh
so i will give a students view of the
thing right so i probably i will be able
to
tell you something that has almost zero
overlap with what all of them said and
they basically cover all of distributed
storage so i don't know how am i going
to do that
uh just to give you a reminder from
distributor from the lightning talk what
i talked about is you have a graph right
over here and then you can store one bit
in any of the vertices of the graph and
with a repair condition that if any
anyone is unavailable you can just go to
the neighbors
to reconstruct that
so
i ask that how many bits of information
can you can can be stored in this graph
with this constant so these are the
recovery set right so for one you can go
to all of them it's not like anything is
small or big
ah so you're given this graph right so
uh because and i as i said there are
many talks
on this
locality topic and then there were many
on gap to capacity and i was just going
back and forth forth between these two
topics and so this this talk is going to
be a might be a bit opposite so i just i
want to put a disclaimer
that don't be offended that if you see
your result in a way that is not
understandable uh hopefully by the end
we will have enough apologies to
everyone
right so uh and if i if i say that some
bound is easy or some bound is hard
doesn't mean that your bound is easier
your bond desire
yeah so we start from this like in 2011
uh or maybe 2010 i i looked at this
bound so you have
so you have a code which has three
parameters n k d right so this is
something we all know this is the length
this is the dimension no matter whether
is it is uh linear or non-linear we can
think of this as dimension is log of the
size of the code and we have some
minimum distance
on top of it you are putting a new
parameter which is locality
ah
i mean by you i mean this
this set of authors and they are saying
that what is this r it is if you lose
any any symbol of a code word you can
look at at most our other symbol to
recover that
and then ah
this n k d r must satisfy this bound
right over here now this bound is uh
looks very much like a singleton bound
so uh what i thought when i saw this for
the first time it looks pretty easy
right and if you just go through the
it's not really difficult to prove and
you are not losing a lot i mean be it
non-linear linear
and someone asked this morning that
whether you can get a counterpart of
this bomb for binary or not and you can
get it it's again it's not that
difficult
because we will come to that why it is
not that difficult uh so it really
doesn't matter but what he uh so
what then i thought is it's this course
are very much like ldpc codes
right so here is again the definition of
locality so you have this code word
symbols right over here and if anyone is
lost you can just go to some other
set of symbols to repair it right so if
you just look at the symbols of the code
words
then for for each symbol you have a
repair group so the uncertainty in that
symbol given this small repair group
that must be equal to 0. so this is
exactly similar to ldpc codes right so
is there any difference like are these
codes
so ldpc codes might be a overkill
because in ldpc codes you have small
local repair group you have much more
than that
you have
but
what would be a good sanity check to see
that these quotes are not really ldpc
codes
right so one way
that i thought at that time was uh just
look at the random error channel or
random erasure channel which no one
really looks at in case of storage so if
you have an erasure channel
and you want to see the
gap to capacity
then our locally repairable code closing
that gap any more than what ldpc codes
can do right so so we know that any ldpc
code is a locally repairable code
but so are they as restrictive as ldpc
codes in terms of reaching the capacity
so that is the kind of question i want
to ask and for erasure channel it's not
very difficult to answer and not only
binary data channel any other eurasia
channel and that will give us some more
insight into this locality problem and
so what really happens
so here is a simple
proof of the gap to capacity of locally
repairable code how much how far away
they are
so if we go back to this bound
you see that if you are in terms of rate
if you are epsilon away from the
singleton bound your locality grows as
one over epsilon order of 1 over epsilon
that actually follows from this one
and that happens for the case of binary
and so on
so let's look at the capacity now
so for to look at capacity
we look at the
entropy at the output of the channel so
suppose i is the set of coordinates that
are erased by b c it can be a q a rated
channel as well
now we just look at the entropy at the
output of the channel
and this is pretty standard that from
thanos inequality we know that if the
average output entropy
of the channel is uh
if the rate is strictly greater than
that then your probability of error is
bounded away from zero
but here we can consider this so this is
kind of a standard exam
thing that you can do for ldpc codes as
well so
so then what you you can you can look at
this output entropy
as a random variable
as a
function of the
channel right so the channel is
introducing random integers
so you can and what we are going to show
that this locality will make this
this uh this random variable concentrate
to some point
which is not exactly at capacity but
little bit far from the capacity
right so
so far so good so we have uh so then we
have to do a little bit trick so if you
have a locally repairable code and you
just shuffle the coordinates of the
local repairable code it remains a local
referral code right now suppose t is the
number of coordinates so for each each
symbol of the locally repairable code
you have a set of co a recovery group
right so suppose t is the set of
coordinates such that the number of the
recovery group actually appears before
it so if you have a linear ordering of
symbols then you are assuming that now
an ordering must exit you can just take
a random permutation and show that there
exists an ordering of this symbol such
that the size of t is always greater
than n over r plus one
okay just do a random thing and average
okay so we are taking that ordering of
coordinates of code right
now
we then we look at this
subset of coordinates in t
whose
repair groups are completely unerased
we are computing this output entropy and
we are looking at the subsets of the
coordinates whose repair group appear
before it and completely unearthed so
those speeds are complete they are just
redundant
so my output entropy must be the size of
the unearthed
positions minus u because use recovery
repair group appear before it it's
completely repairable
so
but on but you know that ah
how much can u be
this expectation of u has to be greater
than equal to 1 minus p to the power r
because all the r locations are non
unerased times t
right so you can so if you take the
expectation of this output entropy
it will be something like this this is
the average version of honeydew
coordinates minus this
right
but now we are done because you know
that this output entropy this is this is
a lipschitz function if you change if
your channel change a little bit it
doesn't change a lot
so not only it's expect this expected
value is this there is like huge
concentration it's concentrated around
this value and just use the standard
martingale argument that has been like
there is age exposure martin
argument or anything for ldbc code so
you basically have
this kind of result
that if your rate if your gap to
capacity is epsilon
then local rep recoverability or
locality is at least
log of one over epsilon
exactly like ldpc code so not only these
codes are
any ldpc code is a locally repairable
code they have the same same gap from
capacity
right
although the proof is a little bit
different
now i am thinking that
okay so they are very much like ldvc
code so i should go back to a graphical
representation of this codes
right and we just had a graphical
representation drawn
sometime back
right over here so it's not like really
ldpc code but
some kind of graphical representation
now here is the
here is what i am trying to achieve at
this point my thought is uh it's not
coherent but here is what i want to do
so in storage i am doing this local
repairs and then if there is a
catastrophic failure i have this
distance guarantee but i still have to
like in uh
sark uh talk is if you have catastrophic
failure you have to go back to reach
solomon decoding it's not that you just
go on doing this local repairs and then
globally corrects correct something even
in storage network right so if you have
one one failure you can go to small
number of other symbols and recover it
but then if you have 10 or 15 failure
you cannot just go on doing this local
repair and convert correct everything
but in ldpc codes you have that kind of
property the local decoding eventually
converts right but this is a different
code so i'm i'm thinking about a
graphical representation and this graph
is nothing but this graphical graph
problem that i talked about right
so you can think about the storage graph
again coming back
and now these are your recovery set
so this graph is just like that
now that i have arrived at this point
i can think of this graph as my storage
topology and i can think that that is
given to us
so let's just formalize this problem it
will just put some form so that we know
that this is well defined
am i going too fast or too slow just
stop me
okay
so i have uh so i can define a storage
code given a graph
what is that so suppose uh
in each vertex i am putting a random
variable x1 up to xn so i have a code
so this is a rdss code that means
recoverable distributed storage system
code
and then i have a set of deterministic
recovery functions that actually maps
from the set of neighbors to
to this this vertices so whatever is the
content of the vertices right and i can
do a lot more things i can actually
relax the definition of recovery i can
have probabilistic recovery i can do
like all kind of relaxation and it's all
wide open
even the analysis that i show uh for gap
to capacity that works only for lasers
for errors i don't know
it's much much harder so it's wide open
and this is so for any coder they must
have this repair guarantee and the
capacity of this graph
we can call it the storage capacity of
the graph
is the maximum size log of maximum size
of such codes
so this capacity is now given on the
storage topology
and
okay
i will give some more motivation as well
but this is this is not really
an artificial problem i then talked with
people and it seems like a pretty nice
model
this is what i did in the case of
lightning
during lightning talk i said i motivated
it by saying that giving some simple
graph and show there is some graph
if we have enough number of servers
where the problem becomes non-trivial
for example for the case of two servers
if i have if i want to store such that i
it is recoverable from the other one i
have only one bit of storage
for the case of 3 i can have 2 bits of
storage
and for the case of 4
2 bits of storage means i have
x y and x plus y
over here
it has the repair condition that if any
one gets destroyed i can just go to the
neighbors and recover it
i cannot store more than two even if i
have four nodes and a topology like this
and here i can store
2.32193 bits
because
yeah if you are in the lightning talk it
is pretty apparent how you do that so
the size of the code that i can store
over here is 5
and this is exactly how you do this
so all these code words are valid if
your recovery functions are this
and these are all non-linear function so
whenever we think of
repair locality we always think about
some kind of parity check but
ldpc code may be
not really linear right so you can make
non-linear ldpc type of code as well
here is an example where the linear with
linear you can store only two bits but
with non-linear you can actually gaining
substantially
this is not one example you can actually
construct
hierarchy of example based on this where
you would be able to achieve this
and
it's quite practical because to consider
this kind of topology because all
servers are not connected to each other
if you look at cloud storage systems
even
and some some links between servers are
easy to establish some links are not
and then there you have to consider for
physical proximity architecture of
different uh storage systems the
platform the connections uh so it's
probably a good idea to even consider a
weighted graph right so when you are
kind of
requesting a server which is far away
you can put a cost on that request
okay so that will generalize this
problem but before just going to that we
want to see whether we can solve the
basic problem
right again uh there is another angle
then uh i saw that this problem is
interesting from
and that is uh there is there is this
this quite popular problem of index
coding that many people are working on
that's actually pretty close to this
problem of storage capacity
and uh just let me just give you a brief
overview of what is index coding problem
so in index coding problem you have a
set of end users
and each want some information so user 1
wants x1 user 2 wants x2 and so on
but they don't have the
they have what they have is a subset of
side information about other users what
the other users want so for example and
that gives you a side information graph
for example here vertex 2 he
this guy wants x2 but he has x3
and x1 by the way all this graph doesn't
have to be
undirected they can be directed as well
all the problems all the questions are
well defined
so 2 once x 2
but it has x 1 and x 3 and so on for all
of the vertices now there is some omnipo
omniscient broadcaster
uh who knows everything now given the
side information graph how much
information does it broadcast so that
everyone gets what they want that's the
index coding problem
okay
it was proposed in this paper first then
there are significant uh progress made
in this other papers index coding is not
the main topic but
uh so i must not just go through it
again for even for index coding it has
been shown that the linear capacity and
non-linear capacity are different
um and so on
so uh do you see the connection is the
correction very
very straightforward it's actually yes
coding and the storage capacity
i think i think that it's a nice
observation the only thing is you're
looking at how much you can store right
in
locality you're also looking for global
distance in addition
which exactly i'll come to yes that has
not been captured here
right
uh
so the kind of the hope is that by doing
this local checks or do something
we might end up having a large distance
i i don't know that yet for example if
the graph is such if you are free to
design the graph for example you can
make it an expander or something like
that so that you do all this local check
but globally also you have a distance
okay but you can given any graph which
might not be expanded you might not have
any control over this graph
then you can put the constant of
distance as well and we will see what
how how does things look like in that
right i think how long do i have
actually
okay okay
good
right so uh so this is actually the
index coding is the source coding
version of the channel coding problem
that we are talking about
and
it can be shown that okay so they can
they are actually a little bit of dual
linear or not so in case of linear if
you have a linear
storage code you can actually look at
the dual code of that linear code it
becomes an
index code that's actually pretty nice
but
even for non-linear they're pretty close
so if you have an index code of length l
then you have a storage code of
dimension n minus l
because you you actually look at all the
set of vectors that are mapped to same
index code so the same message that the
broadcast cluster sends and that
actually becomes uh
becomes an a storage code on the other
side is true as well it's a with a
little bit of gap
and you can prove it um
by doing some random translation because
of the interest of time i'll just
i'll skip that
um
so index coding and this scoring are
quite close and index coding is it has
received some attention this is actually
one of the hardest instance of network
coding
it has been proved so all the hardness
results for network coding they usually
go through index coding and for general
network coding only linear function
capacities
that even that is known to bnp hard so
index coding is pretty hard problem but
the storage capacity problem is not that
hard
and that is not counter intuitive
because here we
we are trying to approximate something
which is n minus index coding right so
even if index coding is hard to
approximate this might not be that hard
and that turns out to be the case
so i will just tell you the case for
undirected graph in the next five
minutes
so what happens in the case of
undirected graph you can show that the
storage capacity is always less than
equal to the minimum vertex cover of the
graph
and
right yeah so that would that happens
because
you see if you have a independent if you
have an independent set in the graph you
cannot store any information in that in
those vertices because whatever
information you put in there they have
to go outside of that set to recover it
the repair group must be because there
is no edge inside that right so
n minus whatever is the size of the
independent set you cannot store more
information more than that information
so you can basically go to n minus size
of the maximum independent set but that
is exactly equal to minimum vertex cover
and also you can have a simple
so you can also store information by
finding a matching in the graph so you
just find a matching in the graph and
then on each vertex
one vertex of the matching for each edge
you put one bit you replicate that on
the other side of the edge right and
because of this simple relation between
max matching and minimum vertex cover
you will always have a two approximation
now you can also show that for general
arbitrary graph improving this two
approximation is pretty hard
because then it will imply a better
approximation more than two
approximation better than two
approximation for minimum vertex cover
which is uh
like dice it's uh the unique game
conjecture has to has to has to be not
true to for that to happen
for the case of undirected graph this is
significantly more involved but you can
still get a log type of approximation
and we i can take question regarding
that
offline
right and ah okay so for directed graph
also you can do something so i think i
have
so whatever time i learn i i will come
to
your question
so what we want is an extra minimum
distance as well
right so
i will say that if you if you want that
condition then you will have a bound
like this
ok
and this bound if you see ok so how do
you do this so you consider an
independent set
such that the size of the neighborhood
of this set
is strictly less than k so less than
equal to k minus 1 say right
now you are just looking at the
projection of the code restricted to
this independent set and its
neighborhood
right
now
that projection because you have the
size
as we said the independent set whatever
information it it has cannot be more
than whatever it's so independent
well because the independent set doesn't
have any information
the entropy of this the the the combined
thing is has to be less than k or less
than equal to k minus 1
right
because it is less than equal to k minus
1 the entropy is less than less than
strictly less than k and the dimension
of the code is k the minimum distance
has to be
because with minimum distance has to be
n minus whatever is the combined size
right and that actually gives me a bound
on the minimum distance so n is this
total number of vertices minus the
combined size of this u the independent
sets and its neighborhood and then i can
try to maximize the size of the
independent set so the neighborhood has
less than size less than equals to k
minus 1. so this is my bound for the
case of
repairability with distance very
probability is given by this graph
now if it were a regular graph
there exist you can show that there
exists an independent set by 2 runs
theorem or something
of size this so you can just plug it in
and you get the simple get back the
simple bound that we started with
right so that's why i said this bound is
not that difficult to compute
um there are other ways to compute this
of course
right uh
so that's basically it i should really
thank my
co-authors vinca chandra greg warnell
so i really skipped the entire
literature of regenerative code i can
i
yeah maybe i can give a different point
of view there as well but that's for
some other time and those who are not
cited during the talk but should really
be cited uh the marquis and kartik shan
mugam they gave me some nice pointers uh
this there is some a work on
complementary index code which relates
very much to the storage codes by uh by
chaudhary langer and springs princeton
tomorrow barg and popeye leopoldos are
just being there i have not in
particular mentioned their work but
they're
i have not spoken about it because
that their work speaks for themselves
and if you are interested in
furthering this topic so i have
something in archive posted last year
you can just search and find it
thank you very much
set time for maybe one or two quick
questions
can you formulate
the
computation of the storage capacity as
some kind of optimization problem so how
would it look like
uh
you can get two approximations through
this but that's very easy
it's a very combinatorial problem there
is no nice formulation
for uh or i don't know any nice
formulation so all even for the case of
directed graph i don't have a two
approximation because there i don't have
a notion of matching right i can
basically go to cycles and try to do
cycle packing
so
but these are all approximately so
direct this problem it has some relation
to shannon capacitance related so i can
only have upper and lower bound and then
try to formulate those bounds
nicely and have some answer but not in
particular i don't have a linear program
formulation for example for this pro
this problem but i can have like upper
bounds on this problem
on which i can right so that's that's my
that's the only approach that i have so
far
is it clear maybe it's a silly question
is it clear that if i increase the field
size
or the alphabet size
the capacity does not go bad and does
that decrease
uh the capacity actually converges to a
limit that you can prove so you can
instead of storing one bit you can store
a
very long
long code right and you then basically
you can normalize by the length of the
code
and that function you can show that it
is
super additive
and like there are so it's basically
converges
so
but the rate of convergence i don't
really know
i have not looked at that
thank you very much